qui i ragazzi raccontarvi della mia vita
tristissima che ogni volta mi succede
qualcosa vi racconto di quando vasco la
ragazza sai che dite facciamo questa
roba
vi racconto di quanto sono stato sfigato
a scuola è vi racconto questo aneddoto
molto carino io quando andavo alle
elementari e alle medie ero molto timido
perché è molto timido anche adesso sono
però sono sempre state realtà però mi
sono ripromesso che io mi sono fermato e
ho detto lorenzo quando tu andrai al
liceo alle superiori tu dovrai avere una
ragazza punto mi sono detto questa cosa
perché perché io ho già dalle medie
desiderava avere una ragazza ma non mi
si pagava nessuno ma nessuno mischia
cavani nessuno troppo bello adesso a
lorenzo ma quanto bello che sei non è
vero ma avresti detto anche prima
tutta parata la palla è come tutte le
sedi che ho avuto nella vita l'ho parate
anche quello
sono andato al liceo e detto mi sono
detto io devo avere una ragazza cioè
cinque anni il liceo ci sono un sacco di
insomma divide opportunità per conoscere
persone quindi io al liceo avrò una
ragazza zoom zoom su di me un attimo ho
fatto unitis quanti voi che hanno
sentito questa frase non sapranno non è
che cos'è uniti spa ve lo spiego io
sapete quante ragazze ho avuto io in
classe in cinque anni di superiori ai
ragazzi provate indovinare video del
cronometro qua cronometro qua 5 secondi
5 secondi per indovinare quanti anzi
scrivete qua sotto nei commenti 5
secondi per chi va nei commenti quante
ragazze secondo voi avuto fa vicini in
classe non dice fidanzati in quante
ragazze popolavano la mia classe delle
superiori in 5 anni 5 secondi tre due
uno via avete scritto bene chi ha
scritto nessuna hai vinto un abbraccio
dal più gran figata al mondo amico mio
ebbene si ragazzi io rick l'asse nella
mia vita ho avuto zero ragazze quindi la
promessa che ho fatto a me stesso di
avere una ragazza alle superiori è
andato subito a farsi benedire perché di
ragazze non ce ne erano proprio quindi
non c'era modo nella mia classe di di
morchia n'è una almeno nella scuola ce
n'erano alcune la risposta è sì ce
n'erano 4 e nella scuola eravamo 2000 ce
n'era anche una quinta ma non era tanto
una ragazza era più un uomo coi baffi e
dunque non c'erano ragazze di tutta la
scuola quelle quattro che c'erano non
erano neanche bellissime però erano le
uniche ragazze che c'erano i titoli
tease quindi l'anno viste come se
fossero tutte 4 belen rodriguez
quindi io non avevo proprio super ma
neanche magra dove sbaglio ci avevo
speranze quindi ho detto vabbè rimarrò
single per tutti e cinque gli anni e
così è stato fin che le ragazze hanno
iniziato a scrivermi perché hanno capito
che potevo essere una persona
interessante perché non giocava solo i
videogiochi no ero malato a tal punto da
poterli registrare video giochi come
vedete adesso solo che oggi la normalità
ai tempi o era un gran figo o era un
gran sfigato insomma era un po non c'era
via di mezzo ora uno ora l'altro dipende
chi guarda vendite però solo in quarta
superiore ho avuto nessuna ragazza
quindi io sono stato quasi fino a 18
anni senza una ragazza mamma mia ragazzi
trame zumbo drillo non so chi è più
fortunato in amore comunque il video
verteva su tutta un'altra faccenda che
però doveva avere questa premessa qui
alle superiori quindi quando ero in
classe
avevo tanti amici almeno quello mamma
mia sono sarei stato uno sfigato totale
quando iniziato a fare youtuber ho
stretto amicizia anche con una persona
in particolare no che chiameremo pino in
questo video non si chiama pino però
sempre non i giudizi nei miei video
perché sennò poi magari le persone
dipendono quindi pipino e pino eravamo
molto amici e allora abbiamo deciso un
anno di andare al lucca comics insieme
tratto dal mio primo anno al lucca
comics
non so se siete mai stati a luca gomis
ragazzi un casino troppa gente che
cammina e io la gente la odio non è vero
noi quello che mi riconoscono tutti
quindi io specialmente non ci possono
non posso vedere niente a lucca comics e
mi dispiace perché il primo anno che
sono andato
mi sono divertito tantissimo e vorrei
tornarci nuova omi camuffo tutto da un
casinò sarà un'altra via primo luca
comics con questo mio compagno di classe
amico pino che avevo conosciuto appunto
alle superiori
abbiamo prenotato all'ultimo un hotel
per andare
lucca comics che era distante anni luce
da luca era distante di buona ventina di
chilometri avrà comunque è la strade
istante dobbiamo prendere il treno per
arrivare by luca vabbè andiamo a lucca
comics come di consueto ogni anno al
lucca comics piove piove sempre non è
che ve la voglio tirare è sempre così
nonostante questo ci siamo divertiti
tutto figo abbiamo trovato una persona
che ci vedeva gli ombrelli
insomma quando piove spuntano da terra i
tipi quelli che ti vendono gli ombrelli
la premessa dell'ombrello non l'ho fatta
a caso ragazzi ci servirà poi dopo nello
strumento polo che useremo più tardi
insomma finisce la giornata
andiamo a cena con i ragazzi vi parliamo
di videogiochi che sono negli ultimo
verso nostro riconoscete finisce la cena
che era mezzanotte i treni per il nostro
allora noi eravamo in un paesino vicino
a luca mi ricordo ancora nome si chiama
porcari aveva mosto tell a porcari pro
questo mio amico abbiamo deliberatamente
deciso di uscire dal ristorante dovevamo
a cena con questi youtubers e andare a
porcari ma persone normali avrebbero
preso ovviamente non solo non c'è il
treno bisogna prendere il taxi per
andare a porcari ok questo mio amico
però questo mio amico ha avuto la
brillantissima idea di dirmi lorenzo
siccome siamo tirchio e più tirchi o noi
due perché invece di prendere italy taxi
e spendere 10 euro 5 euro a testa
attenzione perché non andiamo a piedi
sono venti chilometri teoricamente ce la
dovremmo fare in un paio d'ore io
persona incredibilmente intelligente dal
quoziente intelletivo incredibilmente
sviluppato che cosa gli ho risposto
ovviamente gli ho risposto va bene
andiamo a porcari a piedi era mezzanotte
abbiamo iniziato il nostro cammino verso
porcari saremmo dovuti arrivare verso le
2 di notte più o meno per fare quei
chilometri google maps che ai tempi
funzionava da cani ci diceva
non erano mai due ore lo assicura allora
iniziamo ad incamminarci verso porcari e
prendiamo una strada completamente piena
di terra e fango con gli zaini perché
avevamo gli zaini pieni di roba che a un
prato lucca comics con gli ombrelli
sgangheratissima che avevamo per
arrivare a porcari quindi eravamo nelle
peggiori condizioni possibili però
eravamo combattenti spirito l'iniziativa
andiamo a porcari
badate noi non siamo da di zona quindi
non sappiamo le strade non sapevo niente
avevamo google maps io avevo il telefono
al 30 per cento siccome io sono una
persona con l'intelletto sviluppato non
ho detto vi si scaricherà il telefono
prima o poi non c'è neanche pensato
passa mezz'ora passa un'ora
passa un'ora e mezza ti faccio pino bug
e non siamo tutto questo mentre eravamo
in mezzo al fango alla pioggia pino
guarda e non siamo neanche a metà strada
cioè non siamo arrivati
siamo a un quarto di tutto quello
dobbiamo fare è il telefono di cielo al
3 per cento si sta per spegnere ok
abbiamo fatto una cagata allora potevamo
pensare di fare l'autostop come però non
passava macchina di lì eravamo in mezzo
al nulla a sinistra c'era la foresta a
destra c'era la foresta si sentivano i
lupi ve lo giuro io sentivo di lupi del
nostos che barba chiedete a pino non lo
più non lo chiede velo però potrebbe
dire anche lui giurano nello
sperimentando si sentivano i buchi più
mirava nella peggiore situazione
possibile non potevamo fare niente non
esisteva l'autostop non c'erano macchine
in quel punto quindi l'unica cosa potevo
fare era andare avanti e sperare di
arrivare al punto allora il mio amico ha
detto beh per risolvere problema
facciamo dei piccoli scattini cioè noi
dopo un po che camminiamo ok scattini
per 30 secondi per 30 secondi iniziano a
correre
corriamo 30 secondi e ci fermavamo così
far diminuire la distanza tra noi e
porcari facciamo dei piccoli scattini
randò mitch pino come ma cosa è passato
per il cervello e io pure che ti do
sconto bagnati zuppi tra l'altro pesava
i nostri temi pesavano 20 kg col bagnato
40 e io pensavo meno ricordatevi dei
tempi all'un per cento il mio telefono
si sta per spegnere eravamo spacciati
spacciati in mezzo al nulla alle due e
mezza di notte senza possibilità di non
potevo né andare avanti ne tornare
indietro perché tornano indietro ormai
era la stessa strada per andare in
avanti quindi non potevamo fare niente
potrà un dormire per terra sotto la
pioggia nel fango mi squilla il telefono
e mi chiama mio padre mi ha chiamato
alle due e mezza di notte perché mi
vedeva che era online e mi ha detto mi
ha chiamato di fatto lo ha ri tutto bene
in quel momento
potevo dirgli no papà non è tutto a
posto siamo tutti bagnati fradici siamo
in mezzo a poi era buio pesto io devo
dire no papà non va per niente bene
siamo al buio sento in lupi il telefono
si sta scaricando mancano tre ore per
arrivare a destinazione
non possiamo andare avanti né indietro
se non ci vieni a salvare siamo morti
in quel momento mi sono fatto sto
ragionamento invece gli ho detto papà
tutto a posto e mette giù dopo circa
un'altra ora di cammino arriviamo di
fronte a una tangenziale non so se siete
mai andati in tangenziale quando guidato
quando guidavo suo padre insomma adesso
la giusta il guard rail e dietro ghadry
ci sono quelle stradine che diceva che
che va in gol e stradine di che sono per
lui ecco noi allora pinos come aveva
riconosciuto il suo sbaglio si sacrifica
e fa l'autostop si ferma davanti a noi
questa macchina ciao ragazzi cosa è
successo già che eravamo due con gli
zaini cupi con gli ombrelli sgangherati
io non mi sarei mai fermato e migliore
se fossi stato io quello che guidava ci
avrei lasciati marcire
però questo è stato bravissimo erano due
ragazzi si fermano
il ragazzino è successo io volevo dire
scola amico stupido però non potevo ha
detto no è praticamente siamo partiti
non avete vi prego salvateci la vita va
bene salite a bordo
se siamo saliti a bordo ragazzi eravamo
stremati
ci siamo messi nel sedile dietro gli
avevo detto dov'era l'hotel lo hanno
messo sul loro navigatore noi dietro non
abbiamo detto niente per tutto il
viaggio erano così siamo arrivati
all'hotel e per arrivarci ci abbiamo
messo venti minuti in macchina quindi
per farvi capire a piedi sarebbero state
altre due ore minimo scendiamo grazie
ragazzi grazie mille
no tranquilli non vi preoccupate ci
mancherebbe faccio per scendere dalla
macchina e pino mi dice lori occhio
prendi l'ombrello e io ha già l'ombrello
lo prendo push amo dalla macchina
entriamo nel hotel e ci siamo salvati
così ora questa storia si chiama la
storia dell'ombrello verde perché quella
centrale ombrello verde l'ombrello che
ci avevano venduto a luca non era verde
ramarro gb rettori bill e sgangherato
quando siamo usciti dalla macchina e
pino mi ha detto vari premi l'ombrello
io sì sì ti prendo l'ombrello lo capo
però era buio non vedevo era buio pure
in macchina tuttora buio e poi luca di
notte buia grazie ci avete trovati la
vita ciao mi chiamo in camera poggio
l'ombrello come appoggio l'ombrello lo
guardo e dico ma questo non è il mio
ombrello micai abbiamo potuto l'ombrello
i ragazzi
[Musica]
ma